The next few lessons will cover internet routing.
Contrary to what you might think, the internet
is not a single network, but rather a
collection of tens of thousands of independently operated networks,
or autonomous systems. Sometimes simply called AS's. Networks
such as Comcast, Georgia Tech, and Google, are different
types of autononomous systems. An autononous system might
be internet service provider, a content provider, a campus
network or any other independently operated network. Now
when you're sitting at home on Comcast and
trying to reach content in Google or Georgia
Tech, your traffic actually traverses multiple autonomous systems. This
process of internet routing actually involves two distinct
types of routing. One is intradomain routing, which is
the process by which traffic is routed inside
any single autonomous system. The other is interdomain routing,
which is the process of routing traffic between
autonomous systems. So computing a path between a node
in an ISP like Comcast and another node
in a network like Georgia Tech's involves computation of
both intradomain paths and interdomain paths. In this
part of the lesson we'll look at intradomain routing.
Then we'll study interdomain routing, as well as
the business relationships that make interdomain routing so complicated.
So let's jump into our study of intradomain routing and topology.